hi Armando hi Brooke Brooke and I just
had our seven year anniversary oh
congratulations thank you it's very nice
and she informed me that there is
something called The Seven Year Itch
which I was not aware about and our
question was what do you the three of
you recommend to keep things spicy
I'll speak for myself and say
you've come to the wrong department
store
you just came to the hardware store
asking for milk
where's the milk
um uh well okay I've been married 20
years I what I will be honest that I
think uh the thing that keeps I don't
know if it keeps things spicy but um
because I uh don't even quite understand
that I'm very uptight
um
there's absolutely no Spice in our diet
no no I'm a poor Eliza
Finds Me repellent
um how do you keep things mild
how do I keep things cool to the touch
well I'm going to say uh do you want me
to go I'll go last you go first
quarterly how many years have you been
married I've been married
four and a half years so I haven't even
hit the seven and a half seven year itch
yeah so things are still spicy yeah
yeah yeah you're bringing the the heat
to Pasadena oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
we watch a lot of TV yeah
what about you Sona no I'm like I'm like
girls I we've we haven't been together
that long yet so
we're fine right now but don't babies
you know it interrupts the flow a little
bit yeah they do but yeah
cool
all right I honestly uh I think I think
that's kind of like smoking joints
around the house I think the part the
spicy part of that question is with
what's throwing everyone off because
we're very like
spicy like you know yeah as I said uh I
think this is maybe not uh this for a
different podcast
you came to the uptight hour I mean all
I can say is maybe just try some actual
spices cinnamon something like that
cardamom cardamom one cinnamon was the
spice you decided to go in yeah it's
delicious pepper
let's just list spices
we should have we'd get a spice rack out
here and just read them as we slowly
turn it nutmeg uh I've been married I
guess I'm maybe the most qualified to
answer this uh I've been married I've
known my wife for 22 years and we've
been married for 20 and I was very to be
sincere for a second uh luckiest day of
my life when I ran into her
um she uh it's absolutely fantastic
person we have uh wonderful kids so
that's all good I I'm not kidding when I
say I I still can make her laugh and she
still can make me laugh I swear to God
people say that that's important I think
that's crucial because I I even now I
mean I said something like the other day
that cracked her up legitimately and I
had the feeling of well I'm good for
another few more years and I really did
feel that way I felt like you know
because she she legally could walk away
and
take it all and uh and she may but um
but I but I that's how I feel is that
that's huge yeah that's huge and
remember
when I was really young thinking what do
you mean sense of humor and when I would
hear
um you know I would hear I would see a
beautiful woman being interviewed on TV
and should say I look for a sense of
humor and I'd say no you don't and I'd
have tears running down my cheeks
because that was not my experience but
anyway uh I do think that that's huge I
really think it's huge and
um I know both of your spouses and they
have great senses of humor I think
that's that's huge that's a big big
piece of the puzzle in my opinion